We launched the Parkinson's initiative
with Michael J,
Fox and the Parkinson's institute in out
here,
and we have individuals with
Parkinson's.
We're given a discounted version of the
23 and me,
so we've designed the 23 and me site so
that individuals can get access to their
data,
they can fill out surveys specifically
about Parkinson's as well as about their
general health,
um,
and they get all the other access,
so in information about their ancestry,
they can connect and share with
individuals.
There's a community portion they can
learn from people.
So we want to have a really engaging
experience for people so that we can
keep getting information from them.
So we have one Parkinson survey now we
will plan to have additional Parkinson
surveys because the longterm goal is how
do I get information about you today,
but let's say I want to know how does
your Parkinson's progress in 12 months
in 24 months and 48 months because that
information will be really valuable to
correlate with your genetic information.
So then comes in 23 and we on the back
end,
our researchers in house are actually
analyzing all the data,
so all the information that we're
collecting through the surveys,
they then compare with the genetic
information and what we're finding is
we're actually making really interesting
discoveries.
So I'm on all the different questions
that we're asking about.
So we'll hope to announce soon
information about,
you know,
because as Parkinson's community came
together,
what are some of the discoveries that we
have made and what are those
discoveries,
what kinds of discoveries will benefit
that community.
So that might also integrate with a lot
of the clinical trials that are
happening where clinical trials are
happening,
you know,
either on drugs where we can potentially
help figure out why some people respond,
some people don't respond what,
where there's toxicity or toxicity.
Um,
and some,
a lot of the Parkinson's patients are
eager to participate in clinical trials.
So we might be able to help make sure
that they're,
they can find a clinical trial that
makes sense for them.
I think the biggest problem in clinical
trials is that they're underpowered and
that fundamentally the studies are just
too small and they're designed in such a
way because they're so expensive,
they're designed in such a way that
they're just,
there's a small cushion and so,
you know,
they're expensive to run if you need,
if you need a thousand patients to
really get the clinic the power that
you're looking for,
maybe you have 1100.
Um,
but what we're finding is that those
actually are still under powered.
So the advantage of 23 and me that we
can do is we can actually have huge
datasets where we're not looking to
collect,
you know,
100 people with cancer or a thousand
people with multiple sclerosis.
We want,
you know,
tens of thousands.
So the Parkinson's initiative,
we've announced,
you know,
we have over 3000 people with
Parkinson's in it,
which is,
you know,
on a relative basis,
one of the largest cohorts out there
now.
So we're looking to develop these large
cohorts and keep asking questions.
Um,
I think one of the other advantages that
we have is that we can ask these
Parkinson's patients about their
Parkinson's,
but we're also learning about all these
other aspects of them.
So we asked the general health survey
and then we're asking you about commonly
used drugs,
so,
you know,
do they get a stomach ache when they
take advil,
how do they respond to Benadryl,
things like that.
So it's a cohort where we can keep
learning more and more things from them.
I think we're very focused on
developing,
um,
or understanding the relationship
between genetics and drug response.
And so that could be either on the
efficacy side or the safety side,
but you know,
there's,
it's a well known studies that have come
out that said 50 percent of all drugs
that we take to have no effect on you.
So what we would like to understand is
if you're given a drug is going to
respond yes or no,
and is it going to be safe,
yes or no?
And that's going to be a critical
mission of 23.
And me.